안녕하세요. 기술루트 알렉입니다. 오늘 주제는 바이브 코딩으로 만든 서비스 이거 모르고 시작하면 망합니다. 라는 주제입니다.
참고로 저는 삼성에서 서비스를 운영할 때 하루에 1억 콜까지 유입되는 서비스를 운영해 보면서
실제 수많은 장애를 겪어본 입장에서 이 장애 얘기를 하려고 합니다.
서비스를 운영한다는 것. 그러니까 제가 한 5년 넘게 한 7년 가까이 서비스 운영을 주로 좀 했었는데요.
구축도 하고 만들기도 해봤지만 서비스 운영도 꽤 오래 했습니다. 물론 운영하면서도 새로운 기능을 또 추가하면서 운영을 했죠. 서비스니까.
그런데 지금 바이브 코딩으로 뚝딱뚝딱 만들어지는 것까지는 좋습니다.
저는 운영을 하면서는 분명히 알아야 될 것들이 있고 이걸 어떻게 대응하냐에 따라서 그 서비스가 심지어 망할 수도 있다. 이런 생각 들어요.
이 영상은 끝까지 한번 들어주시는 게 좋을 겁니다. 지금 서비스를 만들고 있든지 구상만 하고 있든지 운영을 하고 있든지 한번 들어주시면 좋습니다.
제가 단연간에 걸쳐서 났던 장애들, 케이스들 그리고 어떤 식으로 복구해야 되는지 그런 것까지도 한번 말씀드려볼게요.
그러면 일단 앱이든 외비든 클라이언트라고 하죠. 앱도 클라이언트고 웹도 클라이언트입니다.
기본적으로 대부분 통신이 될 거예요. 통신이 된다는 거는 이렇게 리퀘스트하고 리스판스하고 있는 상황이고 여기는 서버가 있습니다.
여기죠. 여기가 서버예요. 서버고 여기도 서버예요. 구분을 한 거는 여기는 웹이고 여기는 왓스입니다.
웹과 왓스 구분은 제가 기술로트에 좀 상세하게 적어놨으니까 거기서 좀 참고를 하시면 좋을 것 같고요.
일단 이걸로 한번 들어보시죠. 앱이 안됩니다. 또는 웹이 접속이 안됩니다. 할 수 있죠.
이 때 첫 번째 가장 큰 그림은 여기 디비까지 해서 큰 그림은 어느 구간의 문제인가를 파괴해야 돼요.
무슨 얘기냐면 요구간이 있고요. 여기 구간이 있고요. 여기 구간이 있습니다.
물론 여기를 접속하는 상황에서도 이 웹 어플리케이션 서버 또는 웹 서버가 문제가 될 수도 있고
여기를 접속하는 이 물리적 서버가 문제일 수도 있어요. 조금 한 번 더 풀어 드릴게요. 이렇게
이 그림 그대로예요. 여기 위에는 참고하시라고 이렇게 하는 구간을 나눌 필요가 있다 라는 얘기를 먼저 드리고요.
구간을 나눈다는 의미는 어디의 문제냐 왜 각각 모두가 문제일 수도 있죠. 뭐 그럴 수도 있잖아요.
앱인데 이 사용자가 뭐 네트워크이 지금 안 돼 와이파이도 안 잡히고 뭐 네트워크 그 기능을 꺼두고 접속이 안 된다고 할 수도 있겠죠.
뭐 억지스럽지만 그런 경우는 여기 문제죠.
물론 진짜 클라은트와 문제 있는 경우가 있어요. 앱을 만들었는데 앱에서 통신을 제대로 못한 경우가 있습니다.
그렇기 때문에 일단 앱이나 웹이 정상인지 웹은 그럴 일이 뭐 흔치 않지만 클라은트가 정상적인지를 볼 필요가 있고요.
각각 어떻게 테스트해야 되는지는 이 설명 이후에 말씀드릴게요.
여기에서도 두 가지라고 말씀드렸는데 이 물리 서버가 안 되는지 또는 이 프로그램적인 서버에서 구동되고 있는 웹이나 왓스가 안 되는지를 따로 볼 필요가 있습니다.
그리고 데이터베이스는 좀 별도인데요. 웹까지 또는 왓스까지도 정상적인데 데이터베이스가 안 되는 경우도 더러 있습니다.
그래서 데이터베이스도 따로 볼 필요가 있다라는 거예요.
그렇다면 이제 하나씩 보겠는데요. 일단 클라은트는 비교적 쉽습니다.
일단 내가 있는 환경에서 다른 프로그램이 정상인지 보면 돼요. 내 프로그램만 안 되는 건지 뭐 카톡도 안 되는 건지를 보면 간단히 단말 문제냐 아니냐를 쉽게 판정할 수 있고요.
그러면 이 물리적 서버가 안 되냐 이 서버 이 안쪽에 있는 구동되고 있는 서버가 안 되냐라는 것은 여기 이 서버에는 IP가 있습니다.
IP로 접속까지 되면 일단 물리적 서버는 정상적인 거예요. 대부분 VM이기 때문에 이 VM은 정상이다 라고 볼 수는 있어요.
물론 VM이 안 될 수도 있습니다. 이것을 접속해 보는 방법은 간단하죠. 서버로 접속해 보면 돼요.
접속이 되는지 보면 됩니다. 이 경우도 조금 세부적으로 나눠야 되기 때문에 이게 전적으로 그렇다라고 볼 수 없어요.
왜냐하면 방어벽 같은 개념이 또 있기 때문에 여기까지 일단 보시고 보통은 웹 서버는 엔진엑스나 아파치 같은 서버를
씁니다. 왓스는 탐켓 같은 것을 많이 써요. 제이보스도 많이 쓰고요. 이랬을 때 각각을 볼 필요가 있어요. 서버에서 구동되는 이런 어플케션들은 포트로 접속을 합니다.
그렇다는 얘기는 외부 대부분 80포트. 그리고 왓스는 8080인데 왓스가 꼭 8080이라면 보장은 없어요. 요새 노드로 많이 뛰기 때문에 포트는
다양합니다. 대신에 각각을 엔진엑스도 그렇고 탐켓도 그렇고 그 서버들이 정상적이냐를 볼 수 있는 명령어들이 있어요. 각각.
그러면 왓스가 다운됐는지 웹이 다운됐는지를 보는 겁니다. 근데 경험상 대부분 웹이 다운되는 경우는 별로 못 봤어요. 근데 왓스는 다운된 경우가 많아요.
왓스가 근데 다운됐다는 것보다는 보통 행위 많이 걸립니다. 행위라는 것은 트래픽이 많이 몰려서 더 이상 응답을 해주지 못한 상태로 빠지는 거죠.
그래서 왓스가 문제가 되는 경우 많고 왓스가 문제가 되거나 이랬을 때 또 현상적으로 데이터베이스의 문제가 있는 경우도 있어요.
데이터베이스가 문제가 있어서 데이터베이스가 응답을 못 주기 시작하면 왓스도 자연스럽게 행위 걸립니다. 그래서 전체 시스템이 마비가 되는 거죠. 물론 이러한 것 때문에 MSI까지 나오고 그랬지만 지금 뭐 그렇게 어떤 서비스를 확장시켜서 대응할 게 아니라 간단하게 어떻게 복구하는지 그런 것들을 보시면 되는데요.
일단 대개의 문제는 이렇게 말씀드릴 수 있는데 응급 복구가 있어요. 그리고 정말 근본적인 해결이 있습니다.
그런데 사실은 장애가 딱 나면은 근본적 해결을 하려고 원인을 찾고 그러는 것은 좋지 않아요. 그냥 무조건 복구하는 것이 좋습니다. 복구하라고 합니다. 그리고 대개의 서비스에서는 일단 복구가 먼저죠. 그리고 복구를 할 때는 사실 단순해요.
왓스 같은 경우는 제기도 하면 됩니다. 대부분 웹도 마찬가지고 그게 트래픽을 푸는 방법이에요. 근데 이게 정말 문제가 심각해진다 하면 어떤 현상이 생기냐면 앱이나 서비스에서 계속 트래픽을 시도해요. 특히 웹은 그렇지 않은데 앱은 계속 리트라이를 하는 경우가 많아요.
리트라이를 여러 번 해요. 왜냐하면 이게 내 추억의 문제인지 어떤 문제인지 모르기 때문에 여러 번 호출을 해서 그 연결을 시도합니다. 그런데 그런 것들이 쌓이고 쌓이다 보면 그 트래픽 자체가 이 서버들의 안 좋은 트래픽으로 만들어지는 거죠. 그러면 이제 데이터베이스도 마찬가지고 데이터베이스도 제기동 해야 됩니다. 제기동을 해서 먼저 상황을 푸는 것이 중요하고요. 제기동에도 바로 죽는 경우는
이제 그 방금 말씀드린 트래픽이 과다하게 몰렸을 때 그럴 수 있어요. 그런데 아직 서비스들이 뭐 그렇게까지 엄청난 트래픽을 갖지 않는다고 하면 사실 그 정도 트래픽의 문제라면 당연히 이중화 같은 것들을 해야 됩니다.
특히 웹 말고 와스는 이중화를 해야 돼요. 와스를 이중화해야 되는 이유는 와스의 로드와 그러니까 와스가 처리하는 것과 웹이 처리하는 것은 처음이 다릅니다. 웹은 이미지나 유아래를 요청을 받고 응답해주는 게 대부분이에요.
그런데 와스는 여기에 로직도 들어있고 데이터베이스 접속도 들어있고 데이터도 가져와서 어떤 처리들을 하기 때문에 cpu 자원을 많이 씁니다.
그런데 그러다가 하나가 헹걸려서 안 됐을 때 문제를 이 마스만 제기동 한다고 될 게 아니고 그 시간도 걸리고 문제도 계속될 수 있기 때문에 대부분 이중화를 합니다. 이중화는 아키텍처에 있어서 아주 기본적인 것이죠.
이중화를 해도 http 프로토콜 특성상 한쪽 와스로 갔다가 다른 쪽으로 가도 전혀 문제가 없습니다. 그렇게 해서 데이터베이스는 같은 곳을 바라보는 거죠.
그런 식으로 와스까지 제기동을 해서 문제가 일단 해결이 되는 것이 좀 먼저고요. 지금 낫던 에라 아까 제가 봤던 에라는 사실 dns 에라인 듯 보이지만 어떤 특정 유아래로 접속이 안 됩니다 하는 순간 뭘 봐야 되냐면 몇 가지 중요한 얘기들이에요.
와스는 이중화 정말 중요하고요. 여기서 또 중요한 얘기 하나 드리면 데이터베이스는 백업이 엄청 중요합니다. 물론 클라우드를 쓰시면 어느 정도 자동으로 백업이 기본으로 되어 있어요. 그렇기 때문에 좀 큰 문제는 없지만 그래도 또 항상 신경 써야 될 게 백업입니다.
딱 에라가 발생하자마자 봐야 될 거는 현상이에요. 에라의 현상. 접속 불가인지 에라 코드가 있는지
여기만 봐도 어느 정도 느낌이 와요. 접속이 아예 안 된다. 현상 아시죠. 웹 같은 곳 딱 접속해 보면 아예 접속할 수 없습니다로 떨어져요. 사공사 이런 거 아닙니다. 아예 접속이 안 돼요. 접속이 안 된다라는 현상은 두 가지 세 가지 정도 경우가 있을 수 있어요.
1번. DNS 문제가 있을 수 있어요. 이건 반드시 생각해야 되고요. 2번. 서버가 아예 다운된 경우. 3번. 아까 말씀드렸던 서버 프로그램이 다운된 경우. 그래서 접속 불가인 경우는 도매인. 도매인이 안 되니까 접속이 안 되는 거죠.
그리고 물리적 서버. 물리적까지는 아니더라도 VM레벨에서 다운이 됐다면 접속이 안 됩니다. 그리고 서버 어플리케이션이 다운됐어도 접속 안 되죠.
이 정도 레벨에서 접속 불가가 떴을 때 어떻게 조체해야 될지가 아니고요. 에러코드는 대표적인 게 사공사죠. 사공사 많이 봤죠. 그리고 대표적인 게 5,00. 4,00 에라도 있고요. 4,03 에라도 있어요.
그런데 장애레벨로 낮다고 하면 4,03 보다는 500번 에라가 나올 가능성이 제일 높아요. 서버의 프로그램에 문제가 있으면 서버 프로그램이 문제가 있다. 500번 에라가 나요.
그런데 500번 에라와 서버 다운과는 좀 차이가 있어요. 프로그램 다운과는. 프로그램이 다운되면 그 포트로 접속이 안 되는 겁니다. 그 포트로 접속이 안 된다는 것은 어플리케이션이 이렇게 배견돼서 구동이 되고 있는데.
이걸 접속을 해서 얘가 리턴을 해줄 수 있냐. 아니면 이 자체에 접속을 못하고 돌아오느냐. 이 차이인데요.
접속을 못하고 돌아오는 경우는 접속 불가 메스에 떼는 거고. 접속을 했는데 얘가 어떤 코드를 리턴해주는 것이 이런 에라코드입니다.
상황을 알려주는 거죠. 사공사는 페이지가 없다. 잘못된 접속이에요. 이런 경우는 장애라기보다는 잘못된 정말 잘못된 접속을 하는 경우에 나는 에라고요.
500번 에라는 이 어플리케이션이 다운은 안 됐는데 로직 처리하면서 에라를 뵙는 경우에 꽤 있습니다.
자기가 났을 때도 이런 경우가 현상으로 나올 수 있어요. 일부 서버들이 좀 안 돼서 처리를 못하고 에라를 뵙을 수도 있습니다.
503도 있네요. 503. 503 같은 경우는 뒷단의 서버가 응답을 못해줘서 나도 못해 라고 응답을 해주는 경우에.
에라코드에 대한 또 정확한 내용은 확인을 해보시면 돼요. 저는 지금 전체 그림 가운데 일부를 부분적으로 설명을 드리는 거니까.
이런 식의 에라코드를 확인해서 적절한 대응을 할 필요가 있다.
왜냐하면 물리적인 거나 vm이 다운됐을 때 vm을 기동해줘야 되겠죠. 살려줘야 되는 거고.
다른 에라가 났다면 프로그램을 제기동 해야 되지만 사실은 그런 경우는 프로그램을 복구해야 돼요.
보통 이런 현상은 왜 나냐면 배포라고 하죠. 그 서버의 어플 캐션을 탑재하는 그 배포라는 것을 하게 됩니다.
자주 하게 되죠. 서비스는.
그걸 했는데 직후에 이런 에라들이 나왔다. 그러면 롤 백이라고 해서 기존 프로그램으로 교체해주는 게 좋아요.
거기서 복구하려고 하면 시간도 촉박하고 문제도 잘 생길 수 있기 때문에 그러지 말고 기존 소스로 그냥 덮어버리는 거예요.
기존 소스도 정상인 소스. 그걸로 덮는 게 가장 좋아요.
임시 조치는 롤 백이라고 합니다.
롤 백을 해서 기존 걸로 바로 기존 걸로 바꿔버리는 그런 방법이 있고요.
이렇게 때문에 소스 관리가 정말 중요합니다. 소스 관리를 또 해야 된다.
소스 관리도 해야 되지만 여기 로그라고 적었는데요.
어플 캐션. 백엔더 어플 캐션은 로그를 찍어주는 게 좋아요.
로그를 조금 정말 운영을 하는 경우는 서버를 11도 두고 한 군데만 로그를 찍기도 하는데요.
지금의 서비스를 소규모를 한다고 하면 그냥 로그를 남기는 것도 큰 시스템 부안이 아니기 때문에 로그를 남겨놓는 것이 좋습니다.
이 때 실수하거나 문제가 많이 생기는 경우가 로그를 남기다 보면 로그가 은근 많이 쌓여요.
이렇게 두세 달에 한 번 장에 나는 거는 딱 경험상 이런 로그 때문이 많아요.
로그가 쌓이는 거에 대해서 인지를 잘 못해요. 디비나 이런 것들은 아는데 로그는 텍스로 계속 쌓이다 보니까 그냥 모르고 지나는 거죠.
근데 어느 순간에 디스크가 풀 차는 거예요. 디스크가 풀 차는 장이에요 바로.
그렇기 때문에 로그는 롤링도 중요하고 롤링을 하다가 어느 정도 기간이 되면은 아카이빙을 해버리는 것도 좋아요.
아니면 몇 달 지난번에는 삭제해도 돼요. 사실 몇 달 전 것까지 로그를 볼 일은 거의 없어요.
그러니까 그렇게 하시면 되고 소스 관리는 웬만한 긴 터브를 쓰면 되죠.
백업은 주기를 하루 정도는 줘야 돼요. 일.
왜냐하면 전날 거 정도로 백업하면 아주 큰 문제는 없지만 이것도 한 민감한 서비스를 운영한다고 하면은 하루에 두 번 정도씩 백업을 해야 됩니다.
그렇게 해야 몇 시간의 손실이 있더라도 최선을 복구할 수 있다.
오늘 좀 여러 가지 얘기들을 드렸는데요. 일단 중요하게 그냥 두 가지만 딱 기억하시면 될 것 같아요.
일단 장이가 발생하면 구간. 어떤 구간의 문제인지를 파악하는 것이 중요합니다. 원인 파악이 정말 중요하고요.
그리고 장이가 나기 전에 데뷔. 데뷔는 아까 말씀드린 대로 로그 남기시고 데뷔 같은 경우는 백업.
백업. 그리고 서버 같은 경우는 이중화. 처음부터 이중화하실 필요는 없을 수도 있습니다.
그래도 이런 사전 데뷔 필요하고요. 원인 파악을 할 때 여기까지 중요했던 에라코드.
보시고 에라코드를 이제 전체 포함해서 현상 현상을 보시고 일단은 대응에서는 여기 3번 적을게요.
두 가지를 했는데 대응은 긴급대응. 그냥 일단은 와스나 디비 제기동 하시라.
이거 너무 중요합니다. 그냥 긴급대응 하시고 또 하나는 500번 에라 같은 거. 어플리케이션 레벨에 에라가 나오면 기존 걸로 롤백.
일단 이게 더 좋아요. 롤백 하시고 그 다음에 아주 중요한 거. 근본 원인을 반드시 찾아야 돼요.
반드시 찾고 기록하고 해결을 해 둬야 됩니다. 이거 어떻게 어떻게 해결됐어요. 이거 정말 이건 최악입니다.
그래서 근본 원인 반드시 찾고 해결을 한다. 인증소 오류. 이거 난데없이 나니까 이거 챙겨 두시고 기억하셨다가 저런 식의 양상이 나오면 인증소 오류다.
그래서 복구하시는 이런 내용으로 정리를 해보겠습니다. 좀 유익하셨다면 구독을 눌러주세요.
그럼 제가 이러한 또 영상들 계속 꾸준히 올리도록 하겠습니다. 감사합니다.